i have two water molecules right over
here and typically the water molecules
as they interact with each other they
form these hydrogen bonds that's due to
the polarity of the water molecule we've
talked a lot about that they slide past
each other these hydrogen bonds give
them all these neat properties of water
but chemistry is much messier than
sometimes our diagrams or explanations
show there's all sorts of crazy
interactions all of these things are
bumping into each other in all different
ways and not only are the molecules
bumping in different ways but any given
moment the electrons are jumping around
and and on average they might spend more
time they might spend more time around
the oxygen forming a partially negative
charge at that end and then a partially
positive charge near the hydrogens
because the hydrogens are having their
electrons hogged away from them in fact
this is what forms the hydrogen bonds
but there's always constant constantly
change there because they're all just
jumping around it's all very
probabilistic and so you can imagine
under just the right conditions one
oxygen or one water molecule might just
just graze this water molecule in the
right way that these electrons
that these electrons
get close enough to nab
to nab this hydrogen but it doesn't nab
the the entire hydrogen it doesn't nab
the nucleus and the electron and a
typical hydrogen atom a typical hydrogen
atom actually let me draw it a typical
hydrogen atom
is just a proton is just a proton in the
nucleus actually the most typical
isotope of hydrogen has no neutron so
it's just a proton in the nucleus and an
electron orbiting around it so this
right over here is positive actually
maybe i'll just do it draw it that way
you have a positive proton and then you
have a negative electron you have a
negative electron orbiting around it
actually it's more of a orbital so it's
really this electron is jumping all
around it
but you could imagine these electrons in
this covalent bond they were already
being these were already being hogged
these were already being hogged by this
oxygen in fact that's what was forming
this partial negative charge over here
and a partial positive charge over here
so these would be attracted to this
partial positive charge remember there
you have a partial negative charge over
here this is actually it's forming the
hydrogen bond and actually could bond to
the hydrogen proton while both of these
electrons including one of these
electrons that used to be part of this
hydrogen or you could consider used to
be part of that hydrogen are nabbed are
nabbed by this oxygen and in this
circumstance and i'm not saying that
this happens all the time but under just
the right conditions this actually can
happen and what would result so let me
what would a result is this thing over
here instead of just being a neutral
water molecule
would look like this so you have your
oxygen
you have not only your two hydrogens now
you now have a third hydrogen
you now have a third hydrogen so you
have these two covalent bonds these two
covalent bonds this lone pair
and now this lone pair which i have
circled in blue is now being shared with
this hydrogen proton this electron right
over here of the hydrogen got nabbed by
this oxygen so now you formed another
covalent bond and now this character
over here he's lost the hydrogen proton
but he's kept all of the electrons
so this character over here is going to
look like this you're going to have your
oxygen
is still and now it's going to only be
bonded to one hydrogen
only bonded to one hydrogen
has these two original lone pairs
these two original lone pairs right over
here and then took both of the electrons
from this covalent bond and took both of
the electrons from this covalent bond
and so it has another lone pair so this
molecule gained just a proton without
getting any electrons so if you do that
you're now going to have a net positive
charge for this one over here and this
molecule over here actually let me
let me well let me just write it i want
to write a little bit neater and this
molecule over here so we have this
molecule plus this one this one gained
and this one lost a proton without any
other changes so it now has a negative
charge so just like that you went from
two neutral water molecules to two ions
and these ions this one over here the
one on the left the one that is now h3o
h3o
h3o and it now has a positive charge
positive charge actually i put that o in
a different color h3
h3o
it's a positive charge this is called
the hydronium ion
hydronium
high
dronium and this one over here that is o
h minus
so it's o
h
o
let me get the colors right
h minus
this is called the hydroxide ion or
since it's negative you could call it an
anion but i'll just write hydroxide
high
hydroxide
hydroxide ion right over there so you
have this water it's just kind of
automatically under the right
circumstances this isn't happening a lot
but under the right circumstances you
could you could have one of the water
molecules nabbing just the hydrogen
proton from another water molecule and
that water molecule is going to keep
both of the electrons and then they
ionize they have auto ionized and this
phenomenon this is called the
autoionization of water
let me write that down it's a nice big
word
auto
ionization
auto ionization
of
of water and i really want to make it
clear what happens this hydrogen over
here that you can imagine at first was a
proton and electron the typical isotope
of hydrogen actually does not have a
neutron but then this electron got
swiped
this electron
this electron was part of this bond and
it gets swiped away and so all you're
left is with this proton and this proton
goes to this other water molecule giving
that a positive charge and so you might
say well how how frequently would i find
hydronium ions in water
well the concentration let me actually
draw a little tub of water here let's
say this is a liter of water
this is a
liter
this is a liter of water
the concentration of hydronium in
typical water
the concentration of h3o
the concentration of h3o in typical
water and you put brackets around
something to denote concentration is 1
times 10 to the negative 7
molar and molar this just means moles
per liter this is the same thing as 1
times 10 to the negative 7
moles
moles per liter and now you might be
saying well what's a mole well i
encourage you to watch the video what a
mole is but a mole is a quantity it's
like saying a dozen but it's a much
larger a dozen is equal to 12 of
something mole is roughly equal to let
me write it a mole
is approximately equal to 6.02 times 10
to the 23rd 10 to the 20
third of something and you're typically
talking about molecules a mole a mole of
a substance means six point rough
approximately 6.022 it actually keeps
going times 10 to the 23rd molecules of
that thing so you might say hey 1 times
10 to the negative 7 times 6.02 times 10
to the 23rd that would still get us what
was see this let me actually let me
write down 1 times 10 to the negative 7
moles
per liter
times
i'll do it this way
times 6 i'll just go with 6 since we're
going to go approximately so
approximately 6
times 10 to the 23rd
6th time 23rd molecules
molecules per mole
molecules per mole well these two would
cancel out and you would multiply these
two numbers you would get 6 times let's
see 10 to the negative 7 times 10 to the
23rd that's still going to be 10 to the
16th power
molecules per liter
molecules
per liter so your first reaction is oh
my god i'm going to have 6 time or
roughly i'll say roughly approximately 6
times 10 of the 16th molecules of
hydronium in this that's a lot we should
see it all the time but we have to
remind ourselves there's just a lot of
molecules of water in there as well in
fact a liter of water is roughly so 1
liter of
h2o contains
contains
approximately
56 moles
moles
of
h2o so one way to think about it is i
have one i have one time and if i'm
thinking about a liter of water i have
i'll do it over here i have 1 times 10
to the negative 7
moles
of
moles of h3o
for every
for every 56 moles
moles of h2o so if you look at this
ratio then you start to appreciate the
ratio of 1 times 10 to the negative 7 to
56 let me let me do it down here so this
is the same thing as 1 times 10 to the
negative 7
to 56
is the same thing as let's just multiply
both sides times 10 of the set or the
numerator and the denominator times 10
to the 7th so if we do that this is the
same thing as
one
the ratio of hydronium to
to regular water to hgo 2o is going to
be 1 2 see if i multiply 56 times 10 to
the 7th i'm going to have 5. let me get
right in that same color i'm going to
have
5 6 and i'm going to have i'm going to
throw seven zeros at the end of it let
me do that
one two three four five six seven
so the ratio of hydronium to regular h2o
is one for every 560 million so even
though you might say oh wow look we're
going to have we have a huge number of
molecules of hydronium in this liter of
water for every one of them you actually
have 500 roughly
560 million
molecules of h2o so that should give you
a appreciation for the fact that this
isn't that that typical in fact you're
going to see this much more often than
you see this over here in fact if you
wanted to if you wanted to make these
arrows kind of show which direction the
equilibrium sits in it's actually much
further it's actually much further to
the left so we could make this arrow
much bigger but it also gives you an
appreciation for just how many molecules
you have sitting in a liter in a liter
of water